gee arise how does a CEO gauge whether
their business is at the investment
stage or not do people often seek
investment they don't need yeah I think
also Evan people probably and I saw this
a lot back in the crazy kind of convent
California people raised it's crazy to
set almost too much money and when you
do today it just drives the whole
mentality of the DNA the company in the
wrong direction and it's a real great
sense to almost bootstrap of business
and have that hunger every day and worry
about making payroll and sitting down on
Sunday evening and working at new
expenses your cash flow your pipeline
and all that sort of stuff so I think my
might and I learned this from you
actually it's kind of make money before
you raise money let's build a business
bill buddy for customers and obviously
you need to kind of keep a real-time
weather eye on the cash flow and the
fuel growth which is cash but you kind
of really want to focus on the
fundamentals of business and that's how
would face and that's on the market in
the customers and the value provided and
then you can build a financial model and
it doesn't have to be a
three-dimensional 16 dimensional
spreadsheet can be pretty simple and
then really focus on running the
business and generating the cash you
need to fuel the growth and then go and
get investment when you need to provide
points in time yeah I think the answer
that I think too many entrepreneurs do
start looking for capital too soon and
you're going to lose too much of your
company right because there's a lot of
risk associated with a start-up and any
angel investor VC coming in if they see
a lot of risks and they want more equity
as a result and so the more that you can
show momentum some traction some sales
some media something something that
separates you from everybody else then
your valuation will get much richer and
it'll be a lot easier to close the sales
we would always in the venture capital
firm try to look for companies that want
a growth capital not startup capital so
you've shown a proof of concept that
works if you're selling in a local
geographic market and now you need money
to expand that expansion capitals the
easiest kind of money to raise where the
startup capital is the hardest so if you
don't absolutely need it I try to figure
away to bootstrap it up yeah but the key
thing is when you said that you've got
to know how you can invest money in and
even even the words I use are pretty
pedantic on this I hate the word Spanish
because as soon as you spend money
implies waste if you're ain't you want
to return so as an entrepreneur you
should have a really kind of tight I um
when do you need to raise money to fuel
the work and then you need to know how
you're going to invest at you is no one
just raising money and having two
million dollars in the bank and not
knowing how you're going to deploy it to
gray business and scale that's a really
interesting distinction do you do you
encourage that so you have a staff of
over 10,000 people 14,000 people
something like that do you do you
encourage them to eliminate the word
spend from their vocabulary and look at
invest yeah when I was actually another
co it's about 15 years ago one of my VPS
and marketing came in and you can
imagine it in those days 8080 slide
PowerPoint deck you lose the will to
live and the last slide slide 79 is the
punchline i need a 15 million dollar
budget for a brand campaign or something
happening I said a little bit kind of
get yella fit in the room let's get real
about this and the guy kept on talking
about spend spend spend I said wow we're
not going to spend money in this company
ever like drunk and see if we're going
to kind of focus on investment return on
investment and if what we talked about
before test drive and stuff test drive
stuff till we get the data to know what
really works so we can really scale our
business and I think in the world you
know it's great digital economy digital
marketing everything's accelerated now
so what two years takes weeks and months
now and I think you can really from an
investment point of view you can
actually matter where as I'm sure should
I go for one big lump sum of investment
or should I do it in a number of small
kind of incremental series and I would
always advocate go for kind of small
test drive staff and
you when you don't give away half your
business and lose total control of it
yeah I love that and so again i love the
distinction between spend and invest and
to add to that point of raisin and
rounds uh what you can do is bet on
yourself and so you can raise your first
round maybe a million dollar valuation
and then say hey if I hit these
milestones will you come and fund me but
at a 1.5 million or two million or five
million valuation and so you're betting
on yourself to actually go and hit those
milestones but if you do then it's a lot
less riskier for the investor to get
involved in so you can end up raising
the same amount of money but over time
so you get the money you need to grow
and you've lost less of the company
through dilution